[Musik]
strengere corona maßnahmen gastronomie
kultur und freizeiteinrichtungen sind ab
morgen im lockdown endspurt im us
wahlkampf präsident trump und
herausforderer beiden versuchen ihre
wähler zu mobilisieren
90 millionen amerikaner haben schon
gewählt
massenproteste in belarus die polizei
feuerte warnschüsse ab und nahm mehrere
demonstranten fest
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute am sonntag mit dabei für den sport
kristin otto sehr gern ein schön genannt
ab morgen heißt es vier wochen man zu
hause bleiben und selber kochen stadt
essen zu gehen oder ins kino und theater
auch ausstellungen und museen sind dicht
so wie schwimmbäder und fitnessstudios
schulen kitas und friseursalons bleiben
diesmal aber offen mit diesem
sogenannten teil lockdown hofft die
bundesregierung die zweite welle der
korona infektion zu brechen
julia schröter der letzte tag bevor
geschlossen werden muss der
braunschweiger hof in bad harzburg ist
noch einmal gut besucht viele stammgäste
sind gekommen um ihre treue zu zeigen
die haben gedacht wir gehen noch einmal
es und genießen das noch mal realistisch
ist er weiß box wirklich ende nur wenn
mal wieder aufgemacht wird das hotel ist
ein familienbetrieb in fünfter
generation die nächste zeit bringt
unsicherheit und viele sorgen
auch weil der november in der branche
sonst wirtschaftlich ein starker monat
ist es ist vor allen dingen auch für
unsere mitarbeiter ganz ganz schwer
diesen tag hier heute emotional zu
verpacken das muss man sagen denn nahezu
90 prozent der mitarbeiter werden in die
kurzarbeit geschickt
doch nicht nur die gastronomie trifft es
ab morgen steht vieles in deutschland
still sportstätten kinos bühnen betriebe
es ist der versuch die korona zahlen
wieder in den griff zu bekommen
innerhalb eines tages registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 14.000 177
neuinfektionen der bislang höchste wert
an einem sonntag die neuen maßnahmen
seien einschneidend aber notwendig
betont berlins regierender bürgermeister
ich möchte keine bilder wie wir sie im
frühjahr gesehen haben von kühllaster
mit verstorbenen die durch new york
fahren
und genau darum geht es jetzt zu handeln
nicht irgendwann wenn es zu spät ist
jetzt diese notwendigkeit dürften diese
feiernden vermutlich eher nicht sehen
lautstark und ohne maske straßenparty
gestern in köln
zwar haben es nachtschwärmer insgesamt
an diesem wochenende ruhiger angehen
lassen
ein teil der party macher aber hat es
noch mal richtig krachen lassen bevor
das ab
morgen erstmal vorbei ist in spanien und
italien hat es wieder proteste gegen die
korona maßnahmen gegeben teilweise auch
gewaltsam
so lieferten sich demonstranten und
demonstranten in madrid straßenkämpfe
mit der polizei
auch in anderen spanischen städten gab
es ausschreitungen
ähnliche bilder aus der italienischen
hauptstadt rom
nach zunächst friedlichen
demonstrationen flogen flaschen und
feuerwerkskörper
die polizei setzte schlagstöcke ein
cdu-chefin kramp karrenbauer begrüßt
dass sich die drei bewerber für ihre
nachfolge auf einen termin für den
wahlparteitag geeinigt haben
ich finde es gut dass sie zu einem
fairen wettbewerb zurückgekommen sind
sagte sie in der zdf sendung berlin
direkt die kandidaten laschet märz und
roetgen vereinbarten dass der neue
cdu-chef mitte januar gewählt werden
soll
schauen wir auf die
us-präsidentschaftswahlen da gibt es
bereits einen rekord schon vor dem
offiziellen wahltermin am dienstag haben
mehr als 92 millionen bürger ihre stimme
abgegeben
per brief oder persönlich der ansturm
ist in diesem jahr auch wegen corona
gewaltig sogar halloween hat die
amerikaner gestern nicht vom sogenannten
early voting abgehalten und die beiden
kandidaten gaben noch einmal arts aus
den usa in ist raus auf den letzten
metern wahlkampf unterstützung von
stevie wonder und barack obama joe biden
kämpft um den sogenannten raesfeld wie
hier in michigan vorn liegt er hier doch
der vorsprung ist geschmolzen
es ist zeit für donald trump seine
sachen zu packen und nach hause zu gehen
wir sind fertig mit dem chaos mit den
tweets wut und hass mit misserfolgen
beiden liegt gut im rennen doch es
bleibt sorge bei den demokraten auch
weil schwarze und latinos bislang noch
nicht in großen zahlen gewählt haben
wir müssen wählen wie nie zuvor um das
zurückzugewinnen was gut ist in unserem
land wir dürfen keinen raum für zweifel
lassen zweifel am wahlausgang seht
dagegen präsident trump vor chaos und
wahlbetrug warnt er
nun da der supreme court pennsylvania
erlaubt stimmzettel über den wahltag
hinaus zu werten sehr schlimme dinge
passieren mit den stimmzetteln während
ihr auf den tag wartet bis zu dem sie
aus zählen dürfen viele tage zwischen
den zeilen warnt tram vor unruhen nach
dem wahltag geschäftsbesitzer in den
großstädten verbarrikadieren ihre
fenster nach einem aufgeheizten
wahlkampf könnte der wahlausgang zu
ausschreitungen und protesten führen
egal wer gewinnt rechte militante
gruppen und linke aktivisten drohen mit
gewalt das fbi die polizei und
geschäftsinhaber bereiten sich vor
das ist neu in den usa dass eine wahl
sorge vor unruhen auslöst 2020 es ist
ein besonderes war ja trotz scharfer
drohungen von staatschef lukaschenko
haben sich in belarus zehntausende zu
einem marsch gegen den terror versammelt
wieder forderten sie friedlich
lukaschenko rücktritt empfangen wurden
die demonstrierenden von einem
großaufgebot der polizei für begann
berichtet sonntagnachmittag in minsk
früher und häufiger als zuvor geben
sicherheitskräfte warnschüsse ab gegen
friedlich demonstrierende bela russinnen
und belarussen anfang november gedenkt
das land traditionell der millionen
opfer die stalins terror regime forderte
der marsch gegen den terror heute ist
der gegenwart gewidmet
es ist schon länger kein geheimnis mehr
dass unser alter präsident dem wahnsinn
verfallen ist
wir sind wieder bei den repressionen wie
und das darlehen angekommen
das ist einem genozid schon sehr ähnlich
friedliche menschen so zu bekämpfen
hiermit bin ich gekommen das sind meine
waffen in dieser woche tauscht alexander
lukaschenko den innenminister aus und
kündigte ein härteres vorgehen gegen
protestierende an
wenn irgendjemand einen soldaten langen
und ich habe diesbezüglich die generäle
schon kritisiert muss diese person ihre
hände verlieren mindestens dass der
demokratische wandel nicht mehr
aufzuhalten sein hofft menschenrechtler
alias belasten was unsere gesellschaft
hat sich jetzt verändert menschen die
früher in ihren wohnungen in den küchen
saßen und angst hatten laut sie sagen
was sie denken gehen jetzt auf die
straße
die 10.000 fachen rufen nach freiheit
und fairen wahlen beantwortet das regime
heute mit blendgranaten und festnahmen
auf den philippinen ist der taifun boni
auf land getroffen
die wucht des wirbelsturms hat
mindestens zehn menschen das leben
gekostet
mit windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 225
kilometern pro stunde gilt gorny als
weltweit stärkste wirbelsturm des jahres
fast eine million menschen mussten sich
in sicherheit bringen
katholiken in aller welt gedenken heute
ihre heiligen in fünf deutschen
bundesländern ist der erste november ein
gesetzlicher feiertag
viele besuchen an allerheiligen wie hier
in düsseldorf die gräber ihrer
angehörigen und zünden kerzen an
in diesem jahr gibt es wegen der korona
pandemie einschränkungen auch
gottesdienste finden nur unter strengen
hygiene auflagen statt
tja und jetzt zum sport am sonntag und
christin genau geht gleich rasant los
noch vier wm rennen und die silberpfeile
bestimmen weiter unbeirrt das geschehen
mit dem 5 3 erfolg dieser saison
weltmeister lewis hamilton vor valtteri
bottas schreibt der mercedes rennstall
in der formel 1 geschichte
kein team hat das hier geschafft
siebenmal nacheinander bester
konstrukteur zu sein
die menschen wollen vielleicht wissen
und verstehen wie wir das machen
ganz einfach jedes jahr noch unfassbar
höhere ziele setzen dass mercedes heute
zum fünften mal in dieser saison platz
eins und zwei belegt war zu beginn nicht
absehbar
am start erobert sich max das tappen
position zwei bottas fahren hamilton
dritter eine virtuelle safety car phase
und damit geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
nutzt hamilton zum entscheidenden
boxenstopp er hat genügend vorsprung die
spitze zu behaupten hingegen hat max
verstappen der rechte hinterreifen platz
das aus statt zweiter rang freie fahrt
für mercedes hamilton gewinnt zum 93 mal
bord das dahinter vori kaden dem siebten
konstrukteurstitel wird wohl bald die
dazugehörige fahrertitel folgen das
gehört der mercedes einfach dazu
klarer sieg für bayer leverkusen im
ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga nach 0 zu 1 rückstand
am ende 4 2 beim sc freiburg leverkusen
als tabellenvierter weiter mit anschluss
zum spitzen-trio freiburg bleibt auf
platz 13
liverpools teammanager jürgen klopp in
jubelstimmung den reds haben am siebten
spieltag der premier league die
tabellenführung übernommen
gegen west ham united gelang zunächst
stürmer mohamed salat kurz vor der
halbzeit per foulelfmeter der ausgleich
in der schlussphase erzielte dann diego
dotter das entscheidende 2 1 für den
englischen meister
unter dem strich ein arbeitssieg
liverpool nun mit drei punkten vorsprung
auf irrten spitzenreiter schöne bilder
und so vielen danke christin und wir
haben noch einen blick auf das wetter
für sie morgen vormittag ziehen die
schauer nach osten ab danach lockert es
auf südlich der donau viel sonne bei
stürmischem wind kommt nachmittags von
westen her neuer regen 17 bis 23 grad
so viel von uns für den moment danke für
ihr interesse
das heute journal um 21.45 da spricht
marietta slomka mit dem wiedergenesenen
gesundheitsministeriums sparen